Nos dan esta ecuación de una línea y nos
piden que encontremos las intersecciones
y las usemos para graficar esta línea.
Aquí, la intersección se refiera a cuando
la línea pasa por los ejes "x" y "y",
¿y cuál es la intesección en "x"?
La intersección en "x" cuando la línea toca
este eje, va a ser cuando el valor de "y" sea igual a 0.
Si aquí sustituimos el valor de "y" con un
0, nos va a quedar, -5x,
4 por 0 va a ser 0 igual a 20, ahora despejamos "x" dividiendo todo entre -5,
"x" es igual a -20 entre 5, va a ser 4.
"x" es igual a -4.
Ya encontramos la intersección en "x", -4,
aquí va a estar.
Ahora la intersección en "y".
¿Cuando se intersecta "y"?
Pues cuando "x" es igual a 0,
cuando tenemos esta parte.
Así que ahora, en esta ecuación "x" lo vamos
a sustituir con un 0 y nos va a quedar "4y",
ya que -5 por 0 va a ser 0, igual a 20.
Ahora dividimos todo entre 4 para despejar
la "y" y nos queda que 20 entre 4 es igual a 5.
Nuestra intersección en "y" es "y" igual
a 5, esta parte de acá.
Y ahora solo nos queda unir estos dos puntos
para poder tener la línea que
nos representa esta ecuación.
Recuerden que para dibujar una línea solo
necesitamos dos puntos, así que vamos a tomar
estos dos puntos, de aquí a acá, voy a extender
primero la línea aquí y ahora trataré de
hacer lo mismo pero hacia acá abajo, para
que se vea toda la línea, ahí está más o menos...
Esta es la línea que me representa esta ecuación
y use las intersecciones en los ejes "x" y "y",
para poder encontrar estos puntos
y hacer esta gráfica.
Mis puntos usados fueron la intersección
en "x" que es este punto, -4, 0
ya que la "y" es 0 y mi intersección en "y" que fue 0, 5.
Esos fueron los puntos que utilicé para hacer
esta línea.